my first gig was I was on Late Night
with Conan O'Brien and this is when
nobody listened to him nobody Late Night
with Conan O'Brien and the character I
was a character who didn't make the show
but they still showed the character so
it was funny it was the Amsterdam kids
and it was two kids who were misinformed
about Amsterdam's liberal social
policies maybe I'll put this on air it's
and it was just like hey Conan man I had
this long hair down in my shoulders I'm
like he's like yeah so it's the
Amsterdam kids folks and I go yeah Conan
you know man in Amsterdam you could just
squawk down in the middle of the street
and take a dump and no one will care man
it's performance art cone he's like no
no no no that that's not true no it's
true and we I went on and on and it
turned into like six episodes and it was
so heartbroken when they stopped but you
know what kind of always bothered me
I was a guest on Conan O'Brien and I and
I like Conan
but uh we did a pre-interview you know
the pre-interviews and I said oh I have
a great story because I used to be uh
you know recurring character win the
show when he was just first he goes and
it comes back to me goes yeah Conan
doesn't want to talk about that he
doesn't like to talk about that old I go
it's epic it's epic I never understood
it but I was like oh okay well let's
talk about I guess today's news
oh my God that's amazing it was fine it
was fine so that when you booked that
what was that for you emotionally and
how did how did you tell your parents
did you tell them I still have the
message
um you know
they I don't remember them going wow
this is great you're playing this you
know character on the show that nobody
watches I don't remember them being but
I remember my friend Kent brennaman left
a message which I still have he goes
in bomb
good Lord son I'm turning on the TV and
I see you on there on this Conan or
whatever
dude give me a call
and I gave him a call I hadn't talked to
him for a while and he was a good buddy
growing up and after after that we were
just amazing close friends but I
remember I was like wow he's excited so
it's always fun when your friends are
excited or your friends might watch a
show that you do or because most the
time they're like most the time you do a
lot of work that no one that goes
unnoticed sure because most people don't
have time like I'm like hey man I'm
doing this everybody wants me something
nobody watches